news overseas this morning the foreign
ministers of the g7 countries officially
condemned belarus over the migrant
crisis at its border with poland
overnight polish authorities say they
detained about a hundred people trying
to cross into poland the government in
belarus says it's trying to de-escalate
the situation with repatriation flights
and migrant shelters but as charlie
dagetta reports many families are still
suffering in frigid conditions
they're still trapped in a no man's land
in belarus but they're in from the cold
my finger not work not work in jungle
because so-called i'm my brother
if he die what i am doing
maybe tonight is die but i am come here
and
my life right now is safe the jungle is
what migrants call the outdoor camp at
the border with poland where thousands
have been waiting for weeks to cross
inside nearby warehouses they're
afforded the luxury of food water a
mattress and safety
this woman was found in the forest in
poland said to be pregnant and suffering
from hypothermia
the kind of patients dr arcelon azadine
sees every night what are they suffering
from
dehydration hypothermia and fractures he
said and also injuries there were people
who had been beaten
ruba from damascus suffered a
miscarriage between escaping belarus and
hiding out in poland
she said she had to use water from a
ditch to mix milk formula for her 18
month old baby
in a normal environment a hospital might
serve as a sanctuary for families but
this is not a normal environment ruba
told us she's been separated from her
husband and daughters who've been taken
to a detention facility she hasn't
spoken with them since
all i want to do is hug my kids again
and travel with them to germany she said
she's one among thousands facing an
uncertain future one entirely out of
their own hands
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta bias
podlaski poland